find the sum negative 15 plus negative
46 plus negative 29. so this is the
exact same thing as negative 15. instead
of saying plus negative 46 that's the
same thing as minus
46 adding a negative number is the same
thing as subtracting the positive
version of it or subtracting the
absolute value of it so we're
subtracting 46 plus negative 29 is the
same thing as subtracting
29. so what this is saying is we're
going to start at negative 15
we're going to start at negative 15 let
me draw a number line over here
we're going to start so this is zero i'm
doing it over to the right since
everything we're dealing with is going
to be the negatives we're going to start
at negative 15 let's say it's over here
so this is negative 15 and from that
we're going to subtract 46 so we're
going to move 46 to the left so
this is going to be negative 15 minus 46
and then from this number we're going to
subtract 29
and we'll get us over here so this is
negative 15
minus 46 minus
minus 29 so one way you can view it is
this is going to whatever number this is
going to be this is actually going to be
the same exact number as if we took
positive 15. so let me draw the number
line to the right like this if we had
positive 15
and then added 46 to it so this would be
15 plus 46 and then added 29 to that and
then added 29 but it's going to be on
the other side of zero it's going to be
the negative aversion of this so you
could view this this is the exact same
thing as equal the negative version
the negative version of 15
plus 46
plus
29. these are going to be equivalent in
fact you can see this is if you just
distribute this negative 1 from the
distributive property this is the same
thing as negative 1 times this negative
1 you distribute it on all the numbers
would be negative 1 times 15 which is
negative 15 negative 1 times 46 should
be negative 46 negative 1 times 29 would
be negative 29. so these are equivalent
and now this is pretty straightforward
15 plus 46 plus 29 let's just add those
up
so i'll have i have 46 plus 15
plus 29
6 plus 5 is 11 plus 9 is 20
carry the 2 2 plus 4 is 6 6 plus 1 is 7
7 plus 2 is 9. so this is 90. so this
part right over here evaluates to 90.
now this answer is not 90. 90 would be
if these were all the positive versions
if we had 15
added to 46 to 29 that would give us so
this this would give us get us to 90. a
little mistake here this is
15 plus 46 plus 29 is out here now what
we're finding here is the negative
version of that so we're taking negative
15
minus 46 so that would
and then we said we're subtracting
another 29 so that doesn't get us to 90
that gets us to negative 90. we have
this negative 1 out front so this right
over here is negative
negative 90. anyway hopefully you found
that useful